und jetzt das heute
journal guten Abend die allen zu einem
kurzen heute journal begeht Israel im
gazaastreifen einen Völkermord diese
Frage dieser schwerwiegende Vorwurf
wurde heute vom Internationalen
Gerichtshof in Den Haag nicht
beantwortet nicht mit ja nicht mit nein
sie sollte heute noch gar nicht
beantwortet werden das Gericht hat
allerdings klar gemacht dass es eine
entsprechende völkermordklage gegen
Israel aus Südafrika annimmt und darüber
verhandeln wird das kann Jahre dauern da
es aber jeden Tag neue Opfer in Gaza
gibt und die Zahl der Toten dort
unfassbare Ausmaße annimmt und die
humanitäre Lage verheerend ist wie das
Gericht heute mehrfach betont haben die
Richterinnen und Richter Israel
angewiesen die palästinensische
Zivilbevölkerung zu schützen einen Stopp
der israelischen Offensive verlangten
sie nicht Florian
neuhn wann hat es das schon mal gegeben
ein Gerichtsbeschluss weltweit auf der
Leinwand hier in ramalla Westjordanland
dort in Kapstadt Südafrika und natürlich
in denhag Niederlande vor dem
Internationalen Gerichts überall läuft
live wie die Vorsitzende eines
weltgerichts Israel dazu aufruft einen
Völkermord zu
verhindern das Gericht ist sich sehr
bewusst über das Ausmaß der Tragödie die
sich in der Region abspielt und ist
zutiefst beunruhigt über den andauernden
Verlust von Leben und menschliches
Leiden im Gazastreifen müsse Israel so
das Gericht alles dafür tun
Menschenleben zu schützen und dringend
mehr humanitäre Hilfe zulassen geklagt
hatte die Regierung Südafrikas gehofft
hatte sie auf die Anordnung eines
sofortigen Waffenstillstands doch dem
folgt das Gericht heute nicht die
südafrikanische Außenministerin wertet
den Beschluss trotzdem als
Erfolg um ihn umzusetzen braucht es doch
einen Waffenstillstand ohne kann die
Anordnung gar nicht
funktionieren es ist ein Kampf um die
Deutungshoheit weltweit und Israel nimmt
ihn auf der Vorwurf des Völkermords sei
empörend premier Netanyahu versichert
per
Videobotschaft Israels Respekt für das
internationale Recht ist
unerschütterlich genauso wie unsere
heilige Verpflichtung unser Land unser
Volk zu
Teigen der Kampf in Gaza werde
weitergehen so Netanyahu genauso wie der
vor dem Internationalen Gerichtshof in
denhak der jetzt klären muss ob Israel
Völkermord
begeht ja bringen wir uns Israel
chosponenten mitzu Michael bewerunge
guten Abend welche konkreten
Auswirkungen werden diese Anweisungen
des Gerichts in denhag an Israel den
jetzt haben also ist anzunehmen dass
sich die Lage der palästinensischen
Zivilisten in Gaza deutlich verbessert
also natürlich steht Israel jetzt unter
besonderer Beobachtung den nächsten
Wochen es muss ja auch innerhalb eines
Monats einen Bericht vorlegen was es
denn konkret an seiner Kriegsführung
verändert hat auf der anderen Seite
toben gerade im Moment so heftige Kämpfe
um hananjunis im Süden von Gaza dass ich
mir nur schwer vorstellen kann dass sich
kurzfristig daran etwas ändert von der
Zivilgesellschaft ist auch eher weniger
Druck zu erwarten in diese Richtung
diesem Moment immer noch komplett mit
den Verletzungen den Traumata dieses
Krieges beschäftigt mit den geiselnamen
vor einigen Tagen sind Familien an den
Grenzpunkt Kim Shalom nach Gaza gezogen
haben versucht Hilfslieferung nach Gasa
zu verhindern weil sie sagen solange
unsere Geisel nicht rauskommen möchten
wir auch nicht dass den Menschen dort
geholfen wird und dazu kommt dass die
Medien dieses Landes Fernsehen und auch
print so gut wie gar nicht über die
Situation der Zivilbevölkerung also die
Folgen der Kriegsführung Bericht das ist
schon sehr deutlich spürbar wird auch
ganz offen eingeräumt aber eben auch
damit begründet dass eben die
Zivilgesellschaft momentan solche
Berichte kaum ertragen können die
Analyse aus Israel Michael bwerung
herzlichen Dank dafür so und den
Überblick über das was heute auch noch
wichtig war den hast du jetzt Gundula
auch heute gab es bundesweit wieder
Demonstrationen gegen Rechtsextremismus
und Rassismus es beteiligten sich wieder
etliche tausend Menschen an Kundgebungen
wie hier in Saarbrücken für das
Wochenende sind nach Angaben des
Bündnisses zusammeng gegen Rechts
ebenfalls wieder mehr als 200
Demonstrationen gegen die AFD und
Rechtsextremismus
angekündigt bauernverbandspräsident
ruckwitt hat bei Bundeskanzler Scholz
nochmals auf die Rücknahme aller
Kürzungen im Agrarbereich gedrängt in
Frankreich hat die Regierung nach
mehrtägigen Protesten der Bauern
geplante Erhöhungen auf Agrardiesel
zurückgenommen die französischen
Landwirte protestieren gegen zu hohe
Steuern und
Auflagen Russland soll versucht haben
mit einer massiven
Desinformationskampagne auf der Online
Plattform x und Zufriedenheit mit der
Bundesregierung zu schüren das
Auswärtige Amt habe 50.000 gefälschte
Nutzerkonten von proorussischen Akteuren
aufgedeckt berichtet der SPIEGEL darin
vielfach der Vorwurf auf Deutsch die
Bundes Regierung vernachlässige die
eigene Bevölkerung um die Ukraine zu
unterstützen Außenministerin bärbock hat
im Südsudan zu mehr internationaler
Unterstützung für notleidende
Flüchtlinge aus dem Sudan aufgerufen der
blutige Machtkampf in dem
nordafrikanischen Land hat 7,5 Millionen
Menschen in die Flucht getrieben die
rivalisierenden und kriegführenden
machaber rief bbock zu Verhandlungen auf
er liebt absolut alles an diesem Verein
an dieser Stadt an den Fans und die Fans
die Stadt der Verein sie alle lieben ihn
Jürgen kloppp und Liverpool so eng
zusammengewachsen dass sie nur schwer zu
trennen sind aber klop will genau das
jetzt versuchen der deutsche Premium
Trainer in der Premier League ver
verkündet seinen Abschied zum Saisonende
auch wenn ihm das alles andere als
leicht fällt aber heißt das jetzt coming
home J herlein hat
mehr es ist nicht nur der Erfolg den er
brachte was den Fans des FC Liverpool an
Jürgen klop so gefällt sondern auch die
Leidenschaft mit der er bei der Sache
ist klop hat für die roten alles gegeben
und genau da liegt wohl auch der Grund
seines Rücktritts die Ankündigung heute
morgen wieer hauseigenem tvkanal kam
völlig
überraschend mir wie soll ich es
ausdrücken geht die Kraft aus running
out of energy im Moment geht's mir
absolut gut aber ich weiß dass ich
diesen Job nicht immer weiter und weiter
und weiter machen
kann and again and again again Klops
Power übertrug sich auf sein Team
Liverpools sogenannter Heavy Metal
Fußball brachte sechs Titel in 8 Jahren
darunter eine Meisterschaft und die
Champions League und den Traditionsclub
nach langen mageren Jahren wieder in die
Spur sein offener sympathischer Auftritt
macht klop in ganz England
außerordentlich beliebt
Jürgen ist eine Person die über den
Fußball weit hinaus reicht aber er hat
uns gehört und wir haben ihn
geliebt die Hoffnung dass klop sein
Charisma in Kürze für einen anderen
Verein oder gar die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft zum Strahlen bringt
machte dieser auf einer Pressekonferenz
am Nachmittag dann schnell zu
nichte ich werde auf keinen Fall im
nächsten Jahr einen anderen Verein oder
ein Land trainieren und niemals einen
anderen englischen Club das kann ich
versprechen selbst wenn ich Hunger
leiden müsste niemals und diese Saison
läuft ja noch da kann Premier League
Tabellenführer Liverpool theoretisch
noch vier Titel holen einmal noch
Vollgas
geben und Tennisprofi alexander zwev ist
im Halbfinale der Australian Open
ausgeschieden trotz einer 2:0
Satzführung unterlag der Hamburger in
einem über vierstündigen Match seinem
Dauerrivalen dem Russen danielwed der
spielt nun im am Sonntag gegen den
Südtiroler Jannik Sinner der zuvor
überraschend Titelverteidiger dokovic
besiegt hatte der Verkehrsgerichtstag in
gosla hat sich für schärfere Gesetze
gegen den sogenannten Punktehandel
ausgesprochen wer die Gesetzeslücke
nutze um Flensburger Punkte gegen Geld
an andere zu übertragen sollte mit
Strafen rechnen müssen erklärten die
Verkehrsexperten es sei richtig dass die
Bundesregierung das ändern
wolle das Wetter wird freundlich mild
und bringt Sonne morgen wird es in der
Mitte und im Süden nach Nebelauflösung
sonnig im Norden überwiegen die Wolken
bei 3 bis 8° auch danach im Norden Mix
aus Sonne und Wolken im Süden nach
anfänglichem Nebel viel Sonne etwas
wärmer am Dienstag 7 bis 13° wie
schön so von uns zwei mit diesen schönen
Aussichten danke für heute gerne bis
morgen ausführlich informiert Sie später
unser heute journal Update gegen 015 uh
oder jederzeit ZDF heute im Netz einen
angenehmen Abend ihnen allen und jetzt
viel Spaß beim Handball
[Musik]
tschüss